changed I agree on that right yeah
so would you say that in today's society
men are more traditional or women are
more traditional men men
oh okay yeah at least they try to be
they want you know
why do you think that is so because nah
music no a lot of the time it's it's
with
So within with all the new age feminism
and yeah some of the music some of the
cult some of the things popular culture
that they follow
um women don't feel as if in actual fact
it seems to be negative connotation
attached to tradition being traditional
so even when I said she listens to me
all of a sudden that created a feeling
of something in the chest of until we
explained it but it still created
something submission it seems to be some
nasty word as soon as you say oh she
will submit women hate that word because
submission for them it means that
they can't leave the house they can't do
anything they can't have any friends
they can't wait I'm not saying for you
I'm saying majority of women no I just
saw your face but I'm just just making
it clear but women don't like the word
submission but for us men we it's not a
negative word you understand it just
means that you're trusting our
leadership so so yeah yeah
I want more more men to be made of stuff
that we can trust your leadership
because I think a lot of men in this
Society are leaded from a very weird
place and I get it like it's difficult
what do you mean like I just feel like
they're just
they're just so um
cautious and whatnot and they don't
trust that you know if they meet a good
woman and that she is just she does she
does mean well she doesn't have bad
intentions on whatnot they have this
like elephant in their brain kind of
thing that
doesn't allow them to sorry sorry
um
what was it that you asked me what did I
mean by yeah would that you said they're
weird men are like
weird no quote me what I said you said
they had this elephant in their brain
before that I said this weird oh they
don't trust good women they don't trust
yeah like it's difficult for them to
to be to allow them in there's always
like this Barrett this kind of barrier
of distrust you wanna hear an
interesting stat yeah I'd love to
um did you know that
under 30 one in three men are sexless
they haven't or they're either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
men under 30 one in three are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year where when where everybody yeah did
they ask you this is statistics a lot of
times like when girls will say um like
something like those guys need to be
like they don't want to let us in like
kind of kind of a similar like it's the
tough guy doesn't want to let a good
woman in like you know I don't want to
sorry not disrespect I've just done a
lot of these shows they're talking about
the 20 of men that women want but most
guys are they're down they haven't had
sex in a year one out of three six I
mean like the no they're they're down to
commit I promise to God you kind of if
there's a guy if you've been a Texas in
a year and a girl wants to come into you
you're ready to wipe her yeah because
you want that feeling you want to feel
that feeling again so I think that like
be that being said some guys will settle
for less just to get that feeling yeah
yeah yeah like you've got to remember
like a lot of guys will just settle for
what they can get so it seems sometimes
for you women that are pretty as well
quite hard for you to understand that
men don't get sex because you're
thinking about the top 20 of guys that
you're thinking about but when you next
time walk into a shop but the Tesco's or
you go into
um into Footlocker JD Sports wherever it
is just look at those guys that are
stacking the shows look at those guys
the guys you never see those are these
are the guys that are not getting
anything yeah no no no because um these
are the guys are not that are not
getting any any attention so for me it
it really just comes down to a woman's
choice because it's just the guys you
choose you're you're missing all of the
good all of the all of the guys which
are not on your radar potentially could
be guys that could work for you but you
keep looking at these 20 of guys and
these are the guys if you looked in your
friends if you looked in your DMs it's
not just you it's everyone it's it's
literally everyone because if if you're
single right that means the guys that
you want don't want you otherwise you'd
be with someone I could be with someone
every day
yeah but the thing is you don't want
them which that's the point like anyone
that's single it's the guys you want
don't want you anyone yeah you know
otherwise you'd be with someone yeah but
what's wrong with all the guys that
what's wrong with the 80 of guys those
other guys what's wrong with them what
did you mean like the guys you don't see
what's wrong with them
no I love no swag I love a lazy eye the
buck
can I give me a give me an example
can I can I see someone on Instagram you
don't have to we don't have to put them
on the screen I just want to see if I
actually would like my ex yeah show me
show me one show me one we won't put
them on the screen or anything well
what type of oh hey we got
a new face all right all right bring
your mic closer to you
um hang on let me help you out one sec
let me do it
I had a whole photo
why have you still got photos of your ex
because I made him a um photo album of
all of our time together for his for
Valentine's last year so to print out
all the photos I had to make a folder
I've probably done so he didn't delete
it I think I have because I can't find
it yeah oh no I didn't
wow wow what do you guys okay actually
question for the girls do you guys keep
pictures of your ex no I need to clear
out my hole okay so she does you can't
say no you can't I know I got a better
one no no I'll give it out yes oh wait
she's muted I think
can you talk yeah yeah okay yeah that's
good yeah yeah I do do that but I've
started deleting them now though because
it's that little jump or the Fright that
you get when you see it it's not not fun
is it YouTube pictures no I definitely
delete the pictures because it's so
toxic like why are you reminding
yourself yeah of the person that is no
longer in your life yeah I think it's
more Snapchat memories it's not like I
have an album with them like from
Valentine's Day
I do a scrub after I'm like I can't
because it's Snapchat memories that's
the problem that's it you might just
look at his picture one day and be like
oh my God I wonder who he's with right
now what he's doing I'll be honest Pearl
yeah as a man yeah when you get with a
girl
this and this is I'm going to put this
out to all the guys out there when you
get with a girl you have to be ready to
understand that it's probably at least
five to ten maybe even more I've got
pictures and videos of your girl on
their phone like like so if you think
about old yeah
we're getting the uh the evidence yeah
Sarah if you think about all the girls
that send picture that girl he is not
ugly let me see let me see let me see no
because this is what girls do girls no
but that's because girls only find five
to twenty percent of men attractive
women women find 80 he's not I'd give
him like I give him five six that's what
I guess let's not oh your captain man
your captain your captain yeah yeah he
gets girls he gets girls he gets girls
you don't think five six
kids that's a really nice [ __ ] see
that's Captain for you girl yeah
yeah all right
it's not a bad dude
like women
that are trying to sleep with you so
like if the guy's trying to sleep with
you he'd be like ah now he ain't [ __ ]
and girls find 80 of men unattractive
eighty percent
interesting as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible